seniori mamma mia ke bello aspettare che
attacca la webcam che non ho attivato
ancora una sega aspettare il coach è
stata scritta cosa sbagliata una
descrizione
ok non mi ricordo aspetta che mi mette
un secondo mannaia la morte spiegheremo
mi si vede
porca vacca allora qua a posto perché mi
si dovrebbe vedere se faccio così siamo
persone
ciao persone belle fresche ciao amici
mamma mia che che si sente si vede si si
si gusta si percepisce tutto bene sono
bravi j
non so se hanno dato oggi oggi come ho
scritto nel titolo dovremmo fini sta
minkia realini donation che sei anni che
lo portiamo avanti se dio vuole perché
l'ultima volta è successo l'impensabile
pensavo fini ma non è finito purtroppo
però vabbè eb e co estate ragazzi allora
io vi dico dovremmo ultimata anche ho
detto così per interesse dovremmo
stavolta veramente essere alla fine
quindi come questi c'è finirò vediamo
quanto dura in base a quanto dura poi
faccio magari un bot
favi risponde chiacchieriamo stasera se
finisce troppo presto ok
chiacchieriamo se finisce dopo questo
non vince dopo presso lo conti una
prossima dovrebbe finire se di ore altra
piccola cosa durante la live mi arriverà
da mangiare mangerò quando avrò finito
perché
mi concentro per finirlo però è capace
che che dopo che l'ho finito come si
dice mi metto a mangiare nel mentre
risponde alle domande o salve signor
sergio grazie dei 100 euro di donazione
a caso manco fatto niente non si e mango
visto perché mango avviato il gameplay
che non c'è scritto farci del cazzo sto
bene grazie
molto bene nel senso volevo ancora
iniziata proprio così
grazie park caccia lac bene bene bene
sto bene sto bene sono un po accaldato
perché ogni volta che faceva lei mi
scaldo alzo il volume le innovazioni
adesso parto grazie mille davvero troppo
la partenza così non abbiamo mai avuto
visto che non solo per lei
durante la webcam certo solo conduce di
gioco grazie davvero gentile
grazie knight beh voi cominciamo costo
finale benedetto comprate acqua
no scherzavo non è un placement
[Musica]
sì bene bene
è cambiato il botto è cambiato il volto
benissimo quindi il bot
adesso dice le cose giuste che faccia la
laica alle 9 le 11 ha cambiato tom
thomas non lo sapevo fosse cambiato
meno male grazie tom lo ringraziamo che
ha cambiato tutto il bot
se riusciamo a finirlo dio mi vuole bene
gioca in isole show
contiamo che l'ultima live grazie sergio
basta va bene così cioè tranquillo
grazie entrò troppo che va benissimo
così vive in stato molto gentile
vedo che sia un fan di michael jackson a
minchia sacco mio preferito pezzo
preferito and mirrors tra l'altro io
sono lo so anche io come veri avevo
intuito sono 16 un imitatore di michael
dai veramente avesse fatto caso del
serio injection figo figo che bomba per
posso vedere qualcosa sicuramente grande
grande fantastico io tributi a michael
li adoro cioè mercato ormai grandi
grazie barbas così pronti preoccupato va
bene non ad un sacco troppo grazie mille
ciao che ribatte grazie a gaggi ricky
non c'è bisogno di famiglia donazione
davvero se non faccia live per questo
quindi non no problem
non faccio le live per questo motivo
quindi potete non farlo
sono contento ma tranquilli grazie mille
va tranquillo classificandosi grazie
lavi grazie caterina sto molto bene
grazie mille non ho ancora mangiato però
quindi mangerò no ah sì sì sì ero kwakye
diceva una canzone non ho mangiato
mangerò dopo mangio dopo ma non voglio
quando quando finisco gioco mentre
facciamo domande di uguaglianza nella
luminosità perché questo luminosità te
che la tua alza luminosità del telefono
zilio luminosità giusta
veit
eravamo rimasti che se non vi ricordate
io me lo ricordo benissimo che è
praticamente siamo rimasti che avevo
caldo perché c'è quel giorno mi aveva un
caldo mese c'era sabrina lorenzo la
madonna a casa mia che dovevo registrate
l'europa e quindi devo finire entro un
certo orario e io pensavo di finire il
gioco molto prima non l'ho assolutamente
finito quindi i fan fantastico in
compenso
non ho neanche lanciafiamme quindi
perfetto in compenso sono riuscito a
fare un due ore e mezza di gameplay
senza finire a non cominciamo è facciamo
le cose fatte bene non cominciamo a
cagarmi le palle non stavo correndo non
stava facendo niente quindi come hai
fatto a vedermi vabbè dicevo devo
finirlo l'ultima volta devo finirlo non
son riuscito a finirlo strano ero
convinto di essere alla fine ma non
c'ero
questa volta per forza anzi penso di
finirlo dietro a troppo prima della fine
della live lai finisce alle undici e
mezza secondo me entro le 10 massimo
secondo me abbiamo finito quindi
quindi facciamo un po di fare risponde
in teoria questa live è molto scialla
poi alla fine ci metterò 6 ora finirlo e
dovrò fare altre tre live come mini pro
tu devi stare fermo ti sparo la famiglia
ciao mattia ed è chiara e mario ciao
francesco grazie alla nazione il mio
cane molto carino grazie anche tu grazie
alla ntv vediamo di farlo sta parte
fatta bene ultrà sono morto come niente
come che si attiva da una roba attiva
attiva niente
scusami ma secondo te cosa devo fare
ma che pirla no no sta roba così devo
andare dopo prima devo andare a tirarla
corrente ok non mi ricordo scusate non
mi ricordavo più allora passo qua sotto
grazie emanuele
dittatori michael jackson più sfigata
anche cc alimentato rime con c'è non è
un limitatore lui balla ma limitato la
nostra cosa
conosco jeffrey perez che su youtube è
un limitato di meco che somiglia in a
row balducci nantes e una uguale cioè
per dire ma non gli aspetti piu voce in
chiaro ma cesa corrente adesso posso
aprire speriamo iddio di riuscire a
finirlo direi proprio di sì sennò
finiamo con il mio caro tonfa che mi
protegge quindi devo tenere la molotov
che se mi compare lo zio la tiro e dove
salgono ci fai vedere se non tocca
trottola
no no no per una motivazione non ho
intenzione di renderlo proprio tipo
mascotte del canale come fanno in molti
di più bello cioè
[Musica]
come si dice lui è figlio mio cane non è
il mio non c'entra quel canale non lo
voglio far vedere perché sono anche nei
video importanti la gente scrive quando
lo fai vedere sarà come il mio canale
non c'entra niente col mio cane cioè
tipo molti mi hanno detto anche aprire
un profilo instagram
no no no non è proprio la mia intenzione
di vista che un cane di farlo vedere
troppo cioè nel senso è il mio cane non
è che fa non è che il fa parte del mio
canale quando capita ci faccio veneziane
ok però non lo tiro fuori di tre secondi
grazie sergio ancora stai tranquillo non
c'è bisogno ti meriti non aveva
tranquillo veramente non c'è bisogno
giuro
conosco francesco altrui limitatore sì
non è un imitatore del tipo che lo imita
lui non fa michael jackson lui fa ribal
loeb al ballo al suo stile molto bravo
poi vedo come lo fece non so se ha senso
intimo preferito grazie sono molto
lusingato
grazie mille questo terminale lo out e
dico a te e anche la vittoria se gesù
vuole ciao amico grazie mille a finire
sarà molto bene non mi sono alzato l'ho
detto questo caso mi avvicino troppo
mimì gratis aggrappa alla famiglia non
dico niente non dico facciamo parliamo
zitti e qua finisce tutto in un secondo
dov'è quel presente vabbè ma io rimango
fair con la schiena chinata tutto il
tempo mi salvo da questa navicella che
ciò il mal di schiena a chi se ne frega
nel mentre mi deve arrivare la cena che
ordinato sul già scritto quindi nel
momento lo so che nel momento meno
opportuno arriverà il campania padrin lo
so già nel momento meno opportuno
lo so io tranquilli che lo so devo
andare su ciò una sete in della madonna
perché ho pranzato alle 6 tipo
apprezzato tre ore infatti non c'è tanta
fare per quello non ce la fa ancora
quindi in da bere come acqua c'è un po
ma veramente quindi mi sono ho sprecato
tanto di quel tempo l'ultima volta per
niente c'è un salvataggio ottimo bene
così che bello è molto bello rimasti che
l'unica cosa stavo facendo stavo
cercando di scappare definitivamente la
stazione e stand di piattaforme
già si doveva attraccare con come si
chiama la torrens se basta co sta
precipitando verso il gigante gassoso
saliti sulla torre sexy gigante gassoso
ci sta inghiottendo e sarebbe quello
questo è un gigante che assoluto bene e
quindi dobbiamo scappare prima carinci
ammazzi prima che finiamo sul gigante
gassoso che comunque non è proprio una
bella cosa il gigante gassoso non è che
sia massimo
ciao angie grazie mille la donazione ti
saluto saluto anche alieni che tanto
guarda
grazie mille per la donazione tutti oggi
troppo esagerati tutti che è successo
tranquilli tranquilli davvero non c'è
bisogno così tranquillo troppo troppo
troppo troppo troppo davvero c'è visi
grazie ma vabbè va bene ma se sergio la
mia preferita è miligi avessi o tutti e
si di michael jackson anche al completo
da un frutto di milano
che è quello di di dangerous è
bellissimo poi vi è il geloso e
bellissimo l'altro ho visto che ci sono
siti specializzati per comprendo come di
michael jackson una roba porco demoni
aspetta succhia dove vado
nel mentre che mi scappa la chiusa dare
corri come il demonio in persona
torri tanto da il river salva salva come
il demonio importante dentro
no no no
no rega no fermi zitti o salvato la
partita vuol dire che mi ammazza ogni
volta che gli tornò hanno messo
mandata beh mica incredibile perché ben
spesa se ogni volta che ritornava mi
prendeva avevo buttato il gioco devo
rifare tutto il gioco da zero cioè ma è
andata veramente bene
cioè io ci ho sempre avuto st paura
perché una volta mi è successo in un
gioco non mi dicono quale che ho salvato
nel momenti cui stavo morendo vita
orribile dai niente o morto a
prescindere quindi poteva andare bene
anche il finale di prima ottimo bene
sono morto no tv il panino aspetta un
attimo che storia ecco lo sa per il
momento preciso sapevo li mortacci denis
sorella un attimo accetta aspetto che
arriva
eccolo sorry sorry panino
sapevo che avresti sbagliato la
pronuncia ho sentito in una scena ieri
potter si dice yen a il tuo nome
ok sorry i'm sorry sì se volete pigia
mete vi lascio era una donna grazie di
yen
tu pensi che 2009 prometta bene il 2019
vara se inizia così come come in questo
momento no no penso ovviamente io penso
positivo perché son alien ma quindi non
è finito ma scusatemi ma non voglio fare
lo stronzo però uno alien alla gente
l'ammazza di solito no vabbè
a me no mi ha portato qua e allora
andava bene anche quando mi hanno
ammazzato prima tanto mi portava sempre
4 scusa perché mi ha preso se mi ha
portato qua perché non mi abbia infilato
dei
no no no no no era che non ho niente
proiettili quindi book cioè dicevo a
meno che non mi abbia infilato le uova
ma non penso spero di no perché mi ha
ucciso a tutte le volte che sia arrivato
qua scusa che mi ha preso e potevo non
mi avrebbe mai uccidere panino gameplay
aria in cosa volete della vita vorrei
fare la battuta quell'amaro particolare
ma non la farò perché se sembra di
troppo scontato grazie avanza e vabbè
comunque sta durando un sacco no no no
no no no no no perché esistete nella
vita porto demonio sprecato un colpo di
fucile a pompa lo sapevo non ho colpi
non come come faccio
non ho colpi cosa fa devo fare non ho
colmi e vabbè
e questo era rosso che è successo perché
ci stanno a fà munizioni revolver
io sto sprecando colpi di fucile a pompa
per delle cose ridicole inutili i tuoi
ragnetti guidate dei colpi per cortesia
il tuo regalo preferito ricevuta dai
fans c'era ancora faccio vedere grazie
andrea regalo regalo preferito regalo
preferito lo prendo dopo sono ricordo è
un pop che ho messo l'immagine su
instagram dell'altro giorno è quel pop
fatto a mia immagine e somiglianza di
quello penso sia il più figli più
originale piatto di fatto meglio tra
l'altro fatto veramente molto figo
creatività fantastica non ce l'ho da una
vita
c'è da una vita da un annetto più e
hanno pensato fosse un rumore era il
gioco porca vacca figure si propagano
unacoma nyse la tua non sono fatti
quello che
la palla va benissimo
prestiamo torna la chiusa d'aria tra
l'altro se mi chiama aveva portato no va
bene finché non finisce mai soddisfatto
il mio obiettivo finirlo entro le 10
secondo me ce la dovremo fare anche con
degli avanzi di tempo questo nome
alle 9 45 abbiamo finito però non si sa
mai e l'ultima volta devo finire in
mezz'ora e 2 ora e mezza non lo film
ecco ma si tanto è la cosa più bella che
mi è successa da quando gioca sta roba
quindi chi se ne frega
sono vivo a posto
[Musica]
shell è ok per l'unica roba che io vi
sembrava fatto dalle ciccio questo i
siti che vendono le robe di michael
jackson mi sembrano tutti i siti tipo
metti la carta di credito e ti fottono
la vita ci sono siti fake issimi invece
no e però c'è perché poi costano anche
un bordello costano tantissimo e cosi
michael jackson questo tipo sacco di
ciccio ha fatto vedere che quella giacca
di gang sono stati po 500 fosse mino mi
ricordo il front sacco e io sogno di
avere il guanto una volta c'è un giorno
ciò però non so fare niente for solo il
moonwalk perché facevo solo quello da
piccolo lo faccio male
per ora però non so fare nulla ma mi
sono fiero del mio moonwalk fatto male
salve cristo si sa qui
fammi uscire viva la cui non lo so devo
andare dall'altra parte molto meno
c'è veramente stiamo rasentando il
ridicolo dove devo andare per passare
sta roba possono passare di qua fare
attenzione al fuoco saltare come ci
passo come cipresso ma c'è alieni questa
stessa persona book dove non c'è posto
anche correre però non corriamo perché
lasciate anche perché non ho salvato
quindi non corriamo
non corriamo no minchia
ora che chi è culo pessimi che dovrà
iniziare tutto che palle meno vale mi
hanno dato
ma veramente ci ha dato troppo bene non
mi deve risuccedere ragazze ecco vi
succede neanche per sbaglio visto la
morte in faccia
ma ciò che mi passano una m ogni due
sto a posto proprio una giornata ecco se
nel 2019 inizia così kakà
chi meglio sto morendo la mano che
facesse cadute da te che mi si è ferita
la pagina unità non sa perché adesso la
pagina di youtube delle larve ogni tot
ogni tot mesi frizza perché non so se si
sta ancora vedendo per farvi capire si
sta ancora vedendosi let's go and
friends verso l'infinito e verso il
finale ce l'avete punto sopra salvare
per cortesia telefono telefono telefono
telefono non c'è internet telefono
telefono telefono una sega proprio no
c'è questo
cosa serve non lo so a violino uscenti
molto bene vedi qua
mi sa che decide con tre per forza
perché questa è chiusa ottimo so good e
non c'è fiamme grazie
anzi un aspetto che c'è qualcosa fa
specie cartucce per il fucile e cartucce
per il fucile spiega seguiterà
ho sentito una roba boh ecco bene però
potrei prendere io ma il guanto al
guanto sui però che non so dove si trovi
ban tipo su amazon vendono quelle cose
bruttissime sono i guanti quelli per
pulire i piatti orribile quindi bob se
vengo a roma volentieri anche grazie
molto volentieri
lo prendo i guanti 6 meno aborti se nei
23 che davanti ed avrai miglia
io invece sono stati sensori che cascano
dove vado che sono di qua e non c'è più
vino che va lo smooth criminal è
probabilmente per copyright sicuro
sicuro man tolto per quello animale
vissuto malissimo che ballo vabbè questo
ambito di mille anni fa o non ballava
eccolo a posto tanto sono caduto da
ovunque va bene tanto chissenefrega
pensate sfiga sopravvivi aventi aliena
poi ti schiaccia un ascensore merita
devo muovermi più anche il cast di
assunzione e mi sa che mi sa che se non
mi muovo muoio
è provato e non è accaduto finora
e vorrei sembrare la partita per
cortesia la partita vorrei salvarla la
partita vorrei salvata se non solo la
partita e mi incazzo come una bestia
eccolo qua devo concentrare scusatemi
sgancia torrens
noi ci speriamo
ma devo andare di qua chi non ho caoch
porca vacca morta non ce la farò mai
io non mi ricordo come finisce alien
sganciamo la torrens che se non si è
sganciato renzo a catena
eccola in partenza proprio è rimasta
attaccata ci sta trascinando
nostro che figata che figata beni che si
avvalora la mia tesi che finiscono alle
9 45 euro detto gli ultimi 15 minuti di
alien forse neanche arca vacca che è
successo si stanno staccando pezzi
grossi pezzi enormi che si staccano sono
nella cassetta non so se arrivo alla
fine non so se ce la faccio a mano mi
diminuisce la vita ok perché prima mi
stava diminuendo la vita perché c'era il
gas che pirla facilitato vedevo che mi
andava giù la vita pensavo stessi
morendo di mio ma mai chiamato
all'intestazione diceva e si guarda al
16 festa come tease in festo io qua nel
casino cioè non li si investa una sega
chiama mac e col lanciafiamme un casino
non sto capendo dove c'è come come sta
andando a finire con la faccenda io è
una vita che gioco
se me lo lascia a finire sono contento
usa c'è una scala gigante dai [ __ ]
gigante gassoso
ancora comunque il dibattito dell'altra
volta su come fanno gli effetti speciali
della gravità nei film è ancora non l'ho
capito però è perché non mi sono
documentato nel mentre però non hanno
ancora capito sono ancora il nome lo
spiegherà che quello devo ancora
scoprire
ancora adesso non sto capendo come
faccio a stare attaccato sta roba
però questi devono scalciare io con le
mani sganciato abbiamo qua sotto
tessera l'accesso perfetto abbiamo perso
a no cielo i prodotti di travis sono
accesso
la presa era un distributore di tessere
può va bene allora non l'avete tenere
anche che ci hanno dei sistemi di
sicurezza che fanno ridere
fanno ridere come quelli che nulla che
metta la passata con più al ali al
maghetto e poi scrivono nel computer di
fianco la password la password è questa
grazie un caz te la metti a fare la
bassa da scrive nel computer vicino come
si mette sia una passo di youtube
scritta davanti al monitor anzi fanno da
togliere che via via stessa cioè
distributore delle tessere l'accesso
allora non ammettete neanche sistema di
sicurezza è meglio per noi bella per me
è bella per tutti comunque non ho capito
fai saltare le cariche sullo spaccio di
emergenza
no no no ho visto ti ho visto dove no un
dove due sono le cariche dove sono
steccati le cariche sono qua farle
saltare aspetta che sciali anche mista
salta le salta leste cariche salta tutto
minchia launchpad questo guarda uguale
uguale a ramstein sono martin garics
attiva attivati anche i cd j
porco demonio e mentre c'è alien di
fianco però fa niente così ma tutte e
quattro nel mentre mi avrebbe mangiato
l'intestino avrebbe fatto del mio fegato
poltiglia e dei reni grembiule però non
l'ha fatto
non si sa per quale motivo stanati viamo
le tutte
lo sta facendo la linea si sta godendo
lo spettacolo si è messo a guardare la
live
cosa fa cosa fa lì lì fermo e zitto non
fa niente ti rispondo dopo sergio che
stava tanto da farvi risponde non ho
neanche letto e che sta concentratissimo
double ecco
terra in terra no perché
canterò soprattutto comunque salve se
muori mi fai una cortesia anche tutti
quanti siete
cosa portate
pape ciao sono morti siamo staccati ho
fatto un casino
sono vivo a gesù
vi rispondo a tutti e reagan attimo che
devo finire qua mi rispondo tranquillo
misto e due ore
va bene capodanno a si schianta proprio
quindi siamo morti sono morto no sono
morto
sono entrato nella top nella torrents
sono nella top sono nella torrens non
sono morto
no perché non ha fatto che non aveva
fatto vedere come ero finito quindi si
sono schiantati sevastopol non esiste
più
sono schiantati tutti gli alien sul
gigante rosso dovrebbero essere tutti i
morti in teoria anche se non so come va
qui non è ancora finita definitivamente
quasi raggiungi il ponte a questa è la
prima nave la torrens questa la prima
nave dove sono dove dove mi sono
svegliato all'inizio ma posso mollarla
la tuta no teniamola fa figo bear line e
non è vero
e tante
e uscito dallo stato di voce arrivi a
tanto sono morto ero morto tanto la mia
vita è una mera fai quello che vuoi
della mia vita
intanto guarda sono sinistra per ogni
movimento di promuovere io stato ti in
groppa lo stesso schiacciare il pulsante
schiacciano schiaccia lo sa ci siamo
esposti noi due
quindi
dentro lo spazio wow ok
quindi serviva di continua a vivere si è
svegliata spero vivo mi sono solo
espulso dalla nave ma no dai
ecco perché non me lo ricordavo
ecco perché oggi su vabbè quindi ma
quindi ce l'hanno messo aperto il finale
la filiera aperto sin dall'inizio cioè
nel senso era aperto nel senso che non
si vede che evitanto evviva
si capisce che viva semplicemente non
hanno fatto vedere che si è svegliata
per aviv era rimasto un esemplare di
alien sulla torres che ha ammazzato
presumibilmente tutti perché non mi
rispondeva nessuno lo espulso e sperduto
con me quindi siamo morti perché modo a
cercare spiegazione finale di allison è
piaciuto che l'oggetto allora alien
isole shaun spiegazione finale andiamo a
del primo alieno mi interessano isole
sean hayes all action
alle isole shawn fanning explainers ok
ok lo leggo perché non ho capito ci ho
capito che la il finale c'è scritto il
finale è a libera interpretazione
a è a libera interpretazione nel senso
che le in teoria era già morta quando si
è schiantata da navi la nave
sull'incidente rosso tutto quello che è
successo sulla torre sarà un sogno
in teoria quindi lei non è stata espulsa
lei era già
lippi è stata buttata nello spazio
quando è tornata la torrens sì quindi
era un sogno il pezzettino finale non è
realmente accaduta da un sogno quel
pezzettino dato al ranch sì perché ttt
collocano all'interno della nave a caso
in realtà perché tu vedi che se
all'interno della nave ma non sai come
ci sei entrato infatti quello che dicevo
io sono morto invece non sono vivo sono
io perché in realtà non eri dentro stavi
sognando alla luce la luce che si vede
quando quando quando sta per aprire gli
occhi che lanciata nello spazio potrebbe
essere la torrens che è tornata indietro
per per salvarla quindi realtà non è
morta cioè non era un sogno
l'ultimo pezzo è lei è semplicemente è
stata spazzata via nello spazio quando
la semi lanciato la torres è la luce che
li illumina la faccia dalla torrens che
stava tornando a salvarla questa è
un'altra possibile
interpretazione capito molto bene
gary gray my friends fino a figure che
strano che strano quindi è in realtà è
viva semplicemente non
ebbene avete capito fighissimo sono
molto soddisfatto molto contento l'ho
capito meglio della prima volta la prima
volta sicuro non l'avevo capito il
finale quindi lei dovrebbe essere una
lesione shaun due magari sarebbe molto
figo magari se correggessero un paio di
rho che sarebbe ancora meglio
no non è morta non avete capito
evviva semplicemente non massaggiarmi
quanto vuoi
quanto ti pare anzi anche adesso vieni
qua ti scriviamo non ci iscriviamo
quando i complimenti per la laurea in
fisioterapia il 110 e lode
io una volta ho preso 5 al 6 matematica
non tutte una volta sola è successo mi è
stato un miracolo
grazie e complimenti per la laurea
quindi niente evviva a posto e nello
spazio l'hanno recuperata quindi molto
meglio va bene signori
finito adesso io farei una roba un po
strana farei un po di più e nei cavi
risponde così tanta randomico e è che
poi non si vedono i messaggi adesso
perché persona con la mecca e poi verso
la fine quando ci siano le basi
interrompiamo tanto non è che dobbiamo
timbrare il cartellino il prossimo all
ischia vallin damnation dai adesso
vediamo quando esce adesso chiamo quando
esce poi risponde a tutte le domande che
non ha ancora risposto
tutti quanti mv rispondo quando esce
alien nation halim damnation ace il
teaser ma dai non c'è titolo the
damnation
alien alien isole shaun sequel
[Musica]
sì lo stanno facendo che figata
che figata lo stanno facendo lo stanno
facendo annunciato qualche mese fa bene
dicono che si chiama si chiami ali e
resistenza non alien damnation vabbè
comunque che figo non vedo l'ora di
vederlo molto bello
allora facciamo un po di etica di
cazzeggio time together
se vi va spedita alla fatemi rispondere
a tutte le domande
nel frattempo tengo la musica di
sottofondo di alien piano finisce allora
che non mi dico dove ero rimasto sergio
certo parti sono favolosi in quel sito
che bello grazie jeff l'interesse
bellissima cantare pure a ballare
moltissimi ho sentito cantare
[Musica]
incredibile incredibile canta veramente
troppo simile a michael fincke redimento
ti seguo da sempre visto tutti per
favore ciao cesca grazie di esserci ma
un bacino
ciao giovanni affari scusa non intendevo
farcelo vedere come una scocca il cane
se poi se vuoi inquadrarlo un attimo
comunque sei un grande sta dormendo di
là ho chiuso la porta persona nello
studio quindi non mi andava di
svegliarlo
si no tranquillo ne erano offesa anzi
era solo per dire che non vogliono
intenzione di strumentalizzarlo in tutti
i video per per farvi quando capita una
volta ogni tanto si è visto che non per
carità però nome non lo piazzo in faccia
a video che a meno di 3 secondi non sono
fatto così
neanche gli apro il profilo ovviamente
quanti anni asam ne ha tre mesi
qualche giorno fa i free style con
thomas freestyle che senso cosa vuol
dire che stai lì un gioco è una non ho
capito che cos'è ferita in un gioco se
un gioco va bene meglio lo chiedo non ci
vediamo qual è la canzone tua preferita
di michael man in the mirror
ma in cosa jackass piace dangerous
quella veramente fittissima proprio
bellissima di passioni e si chiama lim
nations
speriamo che esca non adesso perché non
lo rifarei subito
il palle però tra qualche anno lo
rifarei sicuramente ei marghe allora
ciao marghe potresti farmi fare un
saluto da sam e sta dormendo
se lo si sveglia si stanno trovando ciao
l'ora e promettimi che dopo appena poi
come sta venendo il disegno che ti ho
inviato va bene dopo lo guardo su
instagram magari anche in live in
diretta va bene va bene e io allora il
discorso è questo
questo è il messaggio che ho appena
letto solo che volevo in anticipo vada
visto
sta ancora andando voi siccome non
potevo non potevo c'è il discorso è uno
io quando faccio le live
non mi va di fare altri giochi cene
stesso iniziato con alison action che
una serie a e quindi non mi andava di
farne un'altra cioè non so come dirvelo
potrà iniziare un altro gioco però è
brutto nella stessa live per questa la
faccenda orribile quindi vorrei restare
in tema o e ho fatto un paio di sponde o
faccio qualcosa sulla divisa legge anche
comunque finito quindi no però c'è
un'altra modalità che adesso lo devo
vedere un attimo quindi vedo quella poi
magari dopo facciamo fare risponde nel
frattempo di partire tenetevi da parte
delle domande
ok dopo facciamo un mini fare risponde
poi via
ok teneteli da parte le domande che le
facciamo tra un pochettino quando le
palle di fare l'altra parte di allen
isole show che è semplicemente un extra
provo voglio fare almeno già siamo in
tema cambierei gioco ma è brutto perché
poi uno che si guarda tutta la serie
arriva alla fine che faccia iniziale
chinese national isole show nelle isole
shaun the rocket league non ha senso
nello stesso video
ok la modalità però la sopravvivenza
quello volevo fare non so che cosa sia
però volevo provarlo però per curiosità
se mai venuto a frosinone io sono lì
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no no non mi pare sai se un moderatore
dei cani gioca degli altri avere un wow
tra un ballo e l'altro su doni joker
se il validatore top da network per
farli anche la live suoi prima in
pratica tina consigliata a questa la
risposta al
come fanno a fare i films nello spazio
tirano sugli attori con dei cavi e
migliorano i movimenti tramite pc per
renderli più veritieri xvi l'ha svelato
il segreto
io non me lo spiego comunque come fanno
come come fanno non lo spiego non
capisco però vabbè se lo dici tu mi fa
stranissimo charice vediamo sabato ciao
camilla grazie mille ciao chiara sarà
appena arrivata mi dispiace verso il
finale
che sfiga vabbè modalità sopravvivenza
vediamola come potresti avere
dell'anticipazione vadino store e
chissenefrega
cos'è sta roba
ripristina ma non ho capito cos'è
cosa devo fare ma solo per vedere cioè
non è che mi interessa farlo dove io non
l'ho mai fatto per curiosità volo vedere
che cos'era ma non ho capito tempo
limite 30 minuti scappa dalla rea la g
ascensore centrare i preti e ripristina
la corrente lungo la strada ma io non ho
armi o un lanciafiamme hanno capito ho
capito però non ho capito il senso
preparati in alto a sinistra perché mi
spunta gli in ogni 4 secondi non lo so e
la per curiosità non l'ho mai vista sta
parte raccoglie i due badge
dell'equipaggio isola le scale ava tempo
gesù ma a me posso corro da tempo corro
poi sono una ragazza dai capelli
demonio porto
sono una ragazza e ho i capelli dualis i
tuoi capelli quali sono più lunghi
capisci miei problemi ti prego se vi
capisco se sono più lunghi
li capisco fino a un certo punto si sa
che sei messa peggio tutto questo corre
però sopravvivo neanche un secondo e
mezzo su cui corre come isole corpo che
non correre ma corro corri forest cordi
corre vasta isola l'esca su queste le
scale eccole isola letto esci
isola veloce
che roba brutta
non ho capito il senso ma quindi serve
ha isolato la scalata 3.438 bonomi molto
bene ho capito il senso ho finito i
lanciafiamme non posso difendermi ottimo
così quindi se lo becco moio
vabbè ed elimina i dati di sistema da
quei due peggio dell'equipaggio aiutare
sopra una moto
elimina cosa devo fare primi attivisti
tema
gulati fin chiesto sopravvivendo come
non so cosa impossibile
va beh
non c'è niente che posso prendere un
casino stava non ce la farò mai
lasciami fare il mio lavoro scappa
nell'ascensore vabbè no era per vedere
com'era mirano no ma avevo mai visto st
parte della solo per capire che cosa
doveva fare ma non sono buono quindi è
già un miracolo finito il gioco chi se
ne frega no no va beh non importa molto
carino ne faccio a meno
basta usciamo oggi facciamo magari
finiamo fu prima oggi perché un po così
prossime volte magari le faccio un po
più lunga da live che finiscono caripit
ardino a bellissimo libro the cage una
lettere davvero favoloso complimenti
aspetto un altro libro mio libro un
altro libro devo fare seguito ci stiamo
lavorando
vediamo vediamo grazie comunque molto
gentile very very very gen gen gente
buona notte
se avete delle domande e io in questo
momento facciamo fare gli spazi il local
cambio il titolo per adesso mi chiamo
fari favini spa fa vi risponde in live
in cambio la miniatura magari mi faccio
una miniatura un pò carina tipo questa
mi serve una mia foto
perché mentre miniatura così almeno
facciamo un file risponde un pò carino
in borgarina vorrei mettere una foto col
cane così kick beito ma non lo farò
[Musica]
cioè non mia foto decente nomi e foto
perché sono solo sopra insomma mi ero
dimenticato dello zoom sorry e vorrei
teniamo all'inizio le action
chissenefrega se trovo la mia foto ok
allora domande per cortesia intelligenti
oggi sono qua vi rispondo a tutto
vi rispondo a qualsiasi cosa proprio
qualsiasi tanto non ho segreti non sono
una persona che non ha segreti
scaricate una foto randon anzi vi faccio
vedere io che faccio la copertina ma
facciamo così aspetta che la scarico
poteva succedere molto bene molto bene
mi chiamo sam pure io quindi è il cane
ad avere un nome da umano io avere un
nome lacan e noto why un nome da cane
adesso sun è solo un nome da cane da
quando cioè io io uso gimp e per le
copertine su una persona con dei
problemi
ok c'è sono un grafico di seconda mano
portata mente il nostro diventato
conosciuto per le mie doti da grafico
però ok
anzi abbiamo superzoom ata
così che bello da una copertina
veramente strana ma vabbè
ciao cambiamento sta copertina la
tengono solo fino alla fine poi la
cambio evento quella di federation solo
per avere perché ho cambiato il titolo
bene finalmente un italiano alpe che
cambio scusate ma si vede se finalmente
un italiano nello youtube rewind o anzi
anzi anzi anzi
anzi mi ha dato una bella idea adesso
tenetevi le domande incollate dopo che
ne temine domande un attimo lì che poi
adesso rispondo ma prima vediamo lo
youtube rewind insieme è uscito prima ha
in mente i viaggi per il prossimo anno
vado in giappone in tre settimane a far
itinerario quindi vado in giro per il
giappone molto figo
grazie per i complimenti per i privati
adesso lo vediamo youtube
se siete raga ok state vedevo ok pronti
questo allora lo youtube e rewind è un
video che youtube proprio youtube fa
ogni anno questo behind the scenes
dietro le scene che tra l'altro non so
se ci sono nel b and since e non l'ho
ancora visto non penso perché tiene di
sinistra proprio un bel backstage
quindi non credo di essere nel v and
since a 6
guarda lo guarda lo guardano sta male
mamma sono famoso guarda riguarda vista
dal bando o questo video di youtube
youtube spotlight lega youtube spotlight
27 mila iscritti mi scrivono il kit
fighissimo con che rosica
che strano in genere la gente rosica
fichissimo guarda che se avesse il
backstage e belle behind the scenes poi
vi faccio vedere il video completo solo
vedendo l'uomo visto ancora questa prima
volta che lo vedo che esistono i miei
pantaloni cioè senso ci hanno vestiti di
scena io glielo che scrivo i miei
vestiti normali andò uno già bene ero
già vestito strada
cosa va fatto e voluto per sé quando va
bene io giorni white giuliani da youtube
da windows art
sono troppo contento sono una persona
realizzato vediamolo youtube rewind
rispettate come michael non è coronerà
come nessuno nella vita mai michael
neanche io come vado in questo video
soprattutto se per oggi lo vediamo noi
non siete pronti però ok
voi non siete veramente pronti per
vedere questa cosa è fighissimo
[Musica]
siete
questo è il video di youtube rewind c'è
ovviamente wismith io sono in un video
come ok io sono in un pezzettino
minuscolo è perché lo youtube rewind
comprende tutti i clienti normali famosi
del mondo è scenica di capire poi mi
sedetti un bikini io sono i seggi hanno
in israele di trote ci sono il primo
italiano ad esserci del franchi li barba
bene lo sa bene perché non c'è nessuno
era meta di più
anche se non mi freghi doni arriva in
italia
se hai ragione per cui qualcuno
no
credo che da tutto il mondo ero uno dei
più piccoli proprio dei più piccoli in
assoluto quindi miracolo che ci sono i
sottotitoli nei sottotitoli qua a
livello video na figata
mi servono il sottotitolo quando messi
solo la prima weekend dunque l'unica
cosa che non mi piace molto e che
stavolta l'hanno voluto fare molto
parlato
cioè non so come spiegarlo rewind e in
genere molto canzoni e lo è però
stavolta è molto parlato avrebbe ferito
tutte canto canzonato sempre incazzato
come parlo italiano
nessuno
che hip hop style inizio che dovrà mai
un ponte 80
[Musica]
io tra l'altro non riconoscono nice
quasi nessuno li quel non so chi siano
mi riconosco ninja e mesi verso le 9
youtubers mondiali nuovo non li ho
presente come fa molto parlato strano
sinistra di serietà rewind e molto più
uomini
da parecchie
lombardo
ma è un xv di studio marshmallow uno
smash mouth
[Musica]
a livello video impressionante veramente
impressionante un peccato solo che
l'abbiamo detto
se gli altri erano molte ciao figli
secondo me non a livello video ma a
livello proprio così vicino
[Musica]
se li conoscete qualcuno di te e lui e
tom hicks lo fa molto bene andrea e dom
xv rassegna tipi di file
venite a livello video qual è il ragno
di quelli che si vogliono che vogliono
far scorrere l'aracnofobia non sa se
volete quanto questo ragnetto conte
bello se sei ancora racca foto come
l'hai visto se non cattiva persona
stanza si non è che quello figura
dall'asl aracnofobia non è una gara che
non fa mi conviene fracanzino
quell'ordigno scherzi che i suoi giochi
lo era diretto a milano
porca vacca ma la scuola italia in vela
chi è quel liceo ragazza
[Musica]
si sa mai tutto sta parte spezza molto
ritmo e ovviamente sostegno
[Musica]
la scheda più compatte once
h
[Musica]
tra l'altro le lefons in seguito li
ferma in non seguo lei per un motivo che
gli spiego
[Musica]
da tre a un botto di tipo 30 militari
professione
[Musica]
gol ma non assumesse mr
ecco lo aspetta che il mio frame di
gloria
no non è questo per l'amor di gesù
eccolo ci sono le gnocche
e poi ci sono io che sono alto sei metri
però guarda che si guarda che gambara
che slancio è che slancio di gamba
ragazzi che chiappe guardali guardali
guarda guarda ma dove ma dove lo trova
cosa stiamo parlando
[Musica]
lui solo per non far esprimere
guarda lo guarda come si muove il
ragazzo che talento
basta ci dice non si abbandonò non food
i baffi questo è youtube
[Musica]
c'è così come lo vedete tutti voi invece
ciò che è partito rimanendo a metà boom
io sono solo io ma sta canzone
dell'atomo
generi rewind c'è una canzone che per
canzoni conosciute neanche lui conosco
chi è a casa
ora che il cane esame mio adesso è noi
che facciamo
e poi ci sono i canali di tutti i primi
a will smith penso siano in ordine di
apparizione di tutti coloro che hanno
partecipato e vero se li conosco
qualcuno marshmallow lo conosco cosa ti
quando conosco nesso lucas the spider
divertito youtuber do mix è lì che ci
aveva azzeccato ma ci sarà chi link no
mettetevi maledetti
questa roba di sfondo
a harry winder eccolo eccolo lo gnocco
guarda lo guarda lo guarda lo qua
guardalo
mi hanno scritto anche il canale jumba
durano solo fare copia incolla quindi
vabbè bene perfetto sono dopo proxy cioè
prima di pozzi bene in ordine di
apparizione in realtà però che la ninja
un canale di youtube scusatemi no peso
perché curiosità
smith a ninja si si cela evidentemente
no figo molto film cioè strano perché
youtube rewind e molto strano rispetto
però però figo molto figo ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta mancava mister beast e più di
pai la canzone di epr di marshmallow era
quella e io non lo ascolto molto ma non
so chi è ma non lo ascolto cioè
ascoltavo tempo fa speck e le compagne
commenti sul rewind il rewind dell'anno
scorso no semmai vi faccio vedere un
pezzettino di il mio preferito ma va
bene è ben o forse mi copyright a nomi
la showgirl almeno imparato a ridere
mentre la rai che faccio ridere poi è
tra l'altro stavo parlando della tutela
motion perché se voi aveste visto come
eroina non in slow motion quello faceva
ridere quello faceva ride è ovviamente
uscirà nel blog di questo sabato oggi
oggi giovedi sabato uscirà il la mia
esperienza nel rewind quindi ho fatto io
ho fatto i video normali cioè voi non
avete idea libero che vedrete sabato
sabato sarà un video della madonna è una
canzone dei panic at the disco io
peniche aderiscono con li conosco solo
per la cover di bohemian rhapsody solo
per quello non mi ascolto in genere in
genere quel genere scusate il gioco di
parole
conosco solo per quello a tratti sembra
più un porno con video celebrativo asi
guai ma sei tu con la tua ragazza no non
è la fine ragazza quella in mezzo una
delle ragazze una che fai video di make
up sono tutti i famosissimi nel mondo io
sono l'unico italiano
quindi non conosco nessuno conosceva
nessuno ovviamente cos'è quella cosa lì
nelle ponce ah sì lele può anzi
controlla adesso se mi segue in diretta
così vediamo c'è io alle volte non tolgo
i follo alla gente perché mi dispiace
perché magari non mi interessa seguire
certe persone che seguo però se li tolgo
poi magari certe persone vedono che ho
tolto il follo e gli dispiace che l'ho
tolto allora non lo faccio per cortesia
ma sai quanti tanta gente non seguirei
tipo lele ponce vediamo se mi segue
ancora sì mi segue ancora le ponce segui
anche tu perchè perchè non la seguivo ho
smesso di seguirla per un motivo perché
mi dà fastidio tra virgolette quando fa
questa cosa aspetta aspetta e la bella
gnocca perché il tipo conquistava sembro
io tra l'altro stranissimo no ho smesso
di seguirla per un motivo
porca vacca se lo riesco a trovare solo
fa più sabrina lo faceva sempre quindi
possono iniziare a seguirla
perché lei fa ogni tre per due
ogni 3x2 però non lo sto trovando
aspetta non trovo non trovo niente di
quello che vi voglio far vedere in
questo momento strano
porca vacca ecco ho mica prima lo faceva
sempre me non lo fa più lei face faceva
adesso mi rendo conto che questa cosa
che è un prima e dopo cioè fa vedere le
foto di come era e poi fare vedere le
foto di adesso scrive pubertà oppure
scrive
miglioramenti e lo fa ogni tre secondi e
dopo un po la cosa mi è stata troppo in
culo perché abbiamo capito sei gnocca
basta c'è nel senso e non lo eri lo sei
ok una volta ok due volte ok tre volte
ma era pieno di queste foto forse ha
smesso perché gli han detto di smettere
perché io ho smesso di sicura per quello
di ogni una foto su due era una foto di
lei vecchia vecchia nel senso foto del
vecchio lei foto nuova huayra adesso ne
sono trovato un miliardo prima le faceva
sempre ogni tre secondi e non è che una
cosa brutta per carità però lo faceva
sempre c'è una foto su due era così e
quindi la cosa mi piaceva come contenuto
cioè basta ho capito guardava pieno una
bella ragazza per carità però minchia
trasmessi sia perché motivo non perché
non mi è simpatica anzi anzi cosa
c'azzecca vito con quelli di forni tutto
ci azzeccava niente c'azzeccano niente
però va beh lei e crisi non è vero fanno
i video molto divertenti secondo me lele
ponce semplicemente questa cosa è questa
semplice cosa in particolare non mi
piaceva ma
[Musica]
cioè non è che anzi sarà tutto quel
successo perché sono merita sicuramente
vero però trattato a tatò comunque fa
ridere che mi segue una ragazza al 30
milioni di follower e io no
la tata tata tata cosa ne pensi liti si
riesce verso studi bytyci versus più di
pai abbiamo fatto stanno dai serie
perché ci sono ovviamente i canali che
esprimano solo questo porca vacca
questo è lo streaming di uno strip heist
a 74 milioni e mezzo di iscritti
mi fa ridere che ogni volta che
arriviamo che arriva più di pai vicino
al all'essere superato da t series
puntualmente 1 youtuber subentra per per
portare sugli iscritti più di pai prima
è successo lo mark player poi con mister
bis non viceversa data ogni tot qualcuno
subentra per dire dice iscrivetevi a più
di pai quesiti di paese di tre allo
stacco con t series che si riesce il
canale che sta raggiungendo più di paddy
iscritti per chi non lo sapesse e va
velocissimo e più di poi andava molto
lento nel mentre che quando quando
iniziata questa rivalità dipanato
velocità iniziatori cari rifare un sacco
dischi la verità la verità è che secondo
me ha più di palmi ne fregano neanche un
cazzo
però fa ridere il momento ci farà ridere
come proprio
c'è anche a me se mi superò se qualcuno
un giorno non me ne fregherebbe niente
c'è in realtà io in italia sono primo da
togliendo marzio sono primo da una vita
e quindi non mi interesserebbe mai se
qualcuno mi mi superasse di iscritti
quindi mi fa ridere che in realtà pd
paese da questa faccenda ne sta giovando
della serie che sta facendo un miliardo
di views un miliardo di iscritti ma in
realtà non credo gliene frega ma chi se
ne frega di series per parte che non è
neanche uno youtuber t series si resa è
un tipo una casa e metti mi pare fosse
impressione etichetta discografica
indiana quindi sempre come se ammesso
per asse warner che un'etichetta
italiana che probabilmente adesso ore
nel fa più iscritti al giorno di quanti
ne faccio io qui questo un giorno mi
sembra se non è uno youtuber warner
anche se mi supera solo youtuber non me
ne fregherebbe niente di iscritti warner
music ragazzo si chiama
però però a maggior ragione se non è
neanche uno youtuber chissenefrega
vediamo fatto sequenza sta facendo
warner per curiosità comunque non penso
che ha mai veramente non gliene freghi
nulla di questa cosa non fregherebbe non
frega a me figo a tiepidi by warner fa
andiamo a 3 milioni e mezzo e fa 2.500
iscritti al giorno chi meno ne fa più di
me ne fa più di pai se com'è stata la
tua esperienza know you tube rewind sono
stato due giorni a londra due giorni per
quel pezzettino di video giuro su quello
che volete
questo è un kirby me l'ha regalato
giampiero è un kirby molle uno switch 1
square b grazie giampiero per questi
regali meravigliosi lo tengo qua da un
sacco da quando me lo ha dato
io sono maniaco delle cose molli che è
molle
niente e stato molto bello passato due
giorni fa un freddo cane
vedrete nel video di sabato come
l'esperienza del rewind cosa ne pensi di
terra pietistici hanno ragione c'hanno
ragione quanti iscritti 6 siamo boh non
lo so 40 qualche hunter 4 sì sono un
malato di mente ciò il counter degli
iscritti
qui 4.963.000 400 tiepidi by saranno e
dorme non lo prenderò aia la pensi come
ciccio sul fatto degli iscritti no
ovviamente come vi ho spiegato a
scusatemi non ho letto cosa ne pensi del
sum cosa ne pensi del che hip hop e del
successo che sta avendo
il keep hope merita il successo che ha
diversamente da come pensano tante altre
persone per che a parere mio parere mio
perché a me piacciono molto anche
musicalmente per quanto riconosca che
sappiano cantare bene visiva e
visivamente parlando i video chicche hip
hop sono fatti benissimo benissimo
quindi io quando vedo un video che hip
hop dico wow quindi farebbero ad una
milano sicuramente grazie al tea ciao
bianca ha ragione mi riconoscerai la
bionda di tenerife che detto così sembra
di baywatch va bene ciao bianca cediamo
raduno ma già wizard andrea la pop
comunque ti è piaciuto beni a rhapsody
non l'ho visto la pop da pop cosa
bohemian rhapsody non l'ho visto lo vedo
forse domani forse forse lo vedo domani
visto veramente tirato testate al muro
oggi devo farla lei non potevo andare
ieri devo fare una roba non poteva
andare l'altro ieri che dovevo farla rao
fatto live prima perché l'ha salvato
register non son riuscito a vederlo
domani forse lo vedo se non mi pagano
ipantellas che devo andare a cena con
loro vi sto raccontando i cazzi miei
chissenefrega lucri bella loro e ti
segue da un sacco ti voglio bene ti
piacciono i green day guarda
e scontato avere questo come album però
ce l'ho ancora incellofanato cielo
incellophanato e avido e scontato avere
questo però diciamo che li apprezzo lo
aperto perché lo tengo per me perché io
sono molto collezionista quindi mi piace
avere cose di artisti che stimo ti seguo
da di share e che mi grazie luna grazie
leo grazie sniper trattata ta ta ta ta
domande vai vai a cagliari si
cagliaritano son non riesco a farlo dal
dialetto cento non sa 15 sardi ma non
riesco a fare da 100 salva allora che
piace roma si si io continuerei
tranquillamente una mezz'oretta così mi
piace cosa ne pensi del mai dire talk di
ciccio imbarazzante non l'ho visto ho
solo sentito quindi non mi va neanche di
commentare una roba che non ho visto ma
non lo vedo apposta perché so già che mi
incazzo se lo vedo so già che se lo vedo
mi scendono tutti non ci cioè ovviamente
tutti gli altri perché non puoi invitare
una persona e con una cattiveria perché
poi mi ha detto semplicemente che hanno
fatto battute tipo ci chiamerà 89 89
sono i chili il mostro l'incubo degli
all you can eat
vabbè se questa roba fa ridere c'è nel
senso se devi insultare almeno che
facciano ridere cioè non sei
giustificato lo stesso ma almeno che
almeno quello non faceva neanche ridere
non l'ho visto semplicemente mi hanno
detto che hanno detto queste cose
quindi mi sembra la cattiveria gradi
pulitissima e poi non è che l'hanno
dell'anno gli hanno detto a ciccio
siediti stai qua della serie si siede e
abbiamo scherzato verano è entrato
insultato e uscito vabbè non ho capito
chi ce l'ha mandato perché l'ha fatto
non l'ho capito chi ha mandato ciccioli
merla e pazzo non ho capito neanche
perché l'abbiamo trattato così cioè
capizzi so che la gialappa's fa queste
cose ci mancherebbe però il modo e il
contesto soprattutto che non va bene
vabbè davanti come va con l'amore il
mercoledì il venerdì anche gli avanti ti
piace major accademia no devo guardarlo
hai detto percy jackson no non l'ho
letto perché è il mio genere ma non lo è
lo stesso tempo non mi prende riferire
qualcosa in bergamasco non ne ho la più
pallida idea di come si dica conosco il
no non c'entra niente questo dice una
cosa aspetta il pop il pop intendevi
andrea intendevi il fungo poi eccolo
sapere o l'ha scritto adesso l'ha
scritto adesso l'ha scritto adesso e io
gli stavo già rispondendo prima che mi
arrivasse io stavo già rispondendo prima
sono un veggente prima che non l'avevo
letto stavo già rispondendo a questa
cosa intendevo se ci faceva vedere la
finco po più tua di cui parlavi comunque
by mihara psi se fosse consiglio di
rivederlo in inglese
lo rivedrò in inglese perché si danno al
cinema in italia che posso andare mi
scusi mi mette la lingua inglese e tutti
quelli del cinema e panaro non posso
mica vado a prendere il formale mia sono
i quattro non mi fa ad alzare porca
vacca
stavo buttando giù tutto andando di
alzano inciampando su cavi sta buttando
sul televisore quindi ho rischiato la
morte in diretta
questo è il pot mio sembra veramente
vero da vicino si vede che fake
perché se vedete bene cioè delle linee a
lecce veniva degli lineamenti impostare
però è proprio fatto bene benin vice
sono molto altro dietro ci sono è fatto
benissimo che dietro c'è talco lecce
cloud sabri vegas anima suri sterni
vigilia da teco fighissimo finissimo
sono molto affezionato questo è il mio
pop
spiace smr non ho mai visto video se
merli grazie claudio le line le faccio
tutti noi e di tutti i giorni dalle 9
alle 11 e 30 gioco in tutte le live
anche in questa solo con finito
all'inizio non mi va di iniziare un
altro gioco solo per questo motivo
ascolti ancora che i box si che gruppi
non ascolto quasi niente quando mi
capita ascolto una canzone del bts devo
ascoltare l'ultima che uscita per capire
però non mi spero non abbia sveglia non
mi fa impazzire il senso che non mi
piace non ascolto altro capito però non
c'è per carità spero non abbia sbagliato
poi cosa nostra figurati dorme di notte
di giorno si sveglia di notte va
tranquillo ti problema ci sono un pezzo
con l'ala on chip admi copyright hano
raga lo farei ma mi copyright hano di
tutto mi copyright
lo farei è però mi copyright hano il
visitero massei su rewind 2018 non lo so
devo controllare minchia quanti messaggi
raga scrivere altro romanzo prova blu
ma dopo the cage orco demoni mi sono
caricato la perchè non si vede il ma
scusatemi ma allora allert coppia eppure
pur ama perché c'è semplicemente era
sotto adesso le donazioni compaiono qua
era sono io scemo a cera l'alert era
sotto la webcam capito sono io babbo di
minchia
ok niente lo abbiamo aggiustato le
donazioni non si vedono pure scusatemi
oggi incassa premio di tubi c'era un tuo
video di san nicolese fa ma poi j è un
cane io sì ma stai calmo ma anche io
quando ho guardato il video detto mi
chiama un cane
io non ho mai avuto un cane quindi
fighissimo è un impegno perché non può
tutti gli animali non sono giocattoli è
un casino tenere un cane come tenere un
bambino soprattutto perché piccolo fa la
pipì ovunque gratta qualsiasi cosa nord
e qualsiasi cosa gioca mangia fa tutto
quello che fa un essere il e ai suoi
funziona è adesso leggo molto figo un
cane per un impegno quindi volete avere
un cane avete cielo però dategli
attenzioni non trascurate low fat elo
dormire non come l'ultima volta ti ho
scritto mi ha salutato ma non lo hai
letto scusami barbara perdonami ma che
ci sta quella volta che chris mi scappa
una sei stato sfigata mi dispiace perché
gli scritto dovessi far esporre spore
sport però verso poi boh scritto perché
mia zia non ce l'ha fatta no mi dispiace
mi dispiace molto siamo vicino bacino
barbara la cover di ballo dei bts su
michael jackson
no no tutto rispetto
eh no però grazie non lo farò
michael jackson no dovete tocca per
l'amor di dio vi prego
magari sono bravi ma no vi supplico è la
cover ho letto male allora si scusa mi
pensavo avessero fatto un qualcosa che
non avevo capito la cover di ballo ok
scusami non avevo capito non avevo letto
bene perdonami si si scherzava ho detto
alla roba da scemo va bene poi lo guardi
ho letto male la la frase avevo letto
male
ci sono un miliardo di domande scusate
vi sto cercando di pulsar n'è una a il
pomo d'adamo ossia adamo che il como
continua aiello network ma speriamo di
no è difficile che fine ha fatto il
finale the forest il finale di the
forest esce non in shift berlin wall
street by the people esce non non in
live perché the four è stato fatto tutto
in live non uscirà in live uscirà come
video normale domani domani c'è il
finale di the forest in teoria al 99 per
cento a meno che non debbo non devo
cambiare della programmazione all'ultimo
momento di base al 99,9 per cento domani
c'è il finale di the forest come video
normale perché ho registrato già ho
finito le forze per la cronaca
domani civile scherzavo sull'amore
aspettate st arrivano tutte domande
adesso voglio fare una maggiore signora
livelli con temi che controlla rifare un
allevatore azionari anelli absoluto e
viola maratone del sì il signore degli
anelli è però l'ho visto recentemente
non rifare quella dello pit stop
beh il mio disegno in live si come sta
bene e sta dormendo ascolti amal metano
non ma non per cattiveria perché non
ascolto molto la musica italiana
l'ascolto ma non tutti ascolta è
rarissimo che ascolti una canzone
italiana
bravissimo
sta che perde pezzi andrea è stata
attaccata come ti chiami aurora genoa
schiera il tutto il nome e mandata come
scriviamo perché viene nominato di
messaggi auguro ora in ora ricci
molto carina molto carina non si vede
eccola molto carina grazie modi gentili
thank you
ma io non capisco ma allora è
stranissimo perché quando fate le
domande o non me ne esce neanche una o
mi escono domande tutti insieme tutte
uguali
c'è tipo prima all 1 mi ha scritto un
portale perché da quant'è che non porti
scrivere allo sport a scrivere e quella
dopo era porta scribblenauts mica in due
di fila mi hanno scritto il clima
impossibile adesso cosa ne pensi degli
imaging dragons e quella subito dopo
cosa ne pensi dei medici in negozi
uguale vicky assurdo
quante probabilità ci sono che la stessa
domanda due volte perché la pizza con
quei baci in dragons non li ascolto
molto tranne le più famose che sono
bellissime perché la pizza tonda la
danno in cartoni quadrati minchia non lo
sono sempre chiesto sempre sempre sempre
secondo risparmierebbero di spazio
perché non sai quanto la fanno grossa
magari a fano pigro stato il cartone
modo però in realtà sarebbe la stessa
cosa per i cartoni quadrati quindi non
lo so
e vero però è il ora volevo dirti che
ogni giorno aspetto tuo video grazie a
chi me lo chiede oggi mi compleanno
quanti anni fa e cioè le tanti auguri
potesse fare coloriti occupati gli aveva
un ora e le infatti tanti auguri grazie
mille
tanti tanti auguri quanti anni fa qual è
la tua wife
questo vuol dire poi fu e quella c'entra
con le robe sessuali giapponesi ma non
so bene in che senso
vai vuol dire la mia cresce giapponese
negli anime deduco a logica e questo
vuol dire sempre tassino residenti voli
in live il nuovo s
sarebbe proprio figlio
vabbè non spariamo conosci mezz'ora
nelle t wolf conosciuti l'anno bryan si
entrambi mezza nel bellissimo ti volti
non lo seguo perché mi sembra molto e
bello però sembra molto fatto per
ragazzi visto che girano omonia petto
nudo quindi non lo guardo però ha prezzo
quanto sia alto 181 riteniamo quel
centimetro in più la pizza tonda la
mettono nelle scatole quadrate noi la
mangiamo a triangoli e poi dicono che la
terra è tonda quando tornò a geo guess
la terra è piatta proprio per gessa
guardate giochi esser quella quella è la
più grande prova della terra del terrà
piattismo
trattata ma la tua comparsa da youtube
rewind minchia lega non avete visto
l'inizio della live
pensate di farti una votare i capelli no
ti prego com'ero prima già un miracolo
si possa solo peggiorare
posso solo peggiorare e vedendo la
nostra giorni tok e hull no l'ho vista
ho visto la prima e basta sono tori
dreams non lo posso fare perché tutto
uguale non ci sono mappe nuove capito
quindi il labbro lo farei ma mi sa che
si è detto lo schermo davanti borgo
meglio sembrano quarto dritto mi sto
sorgendo il collo ascolti musiche di m
un sacco un sacco i pavoni domineranno
il mondo si sa me vivo si sta dormendo
ti piace ovviamente irma dersi
[Applauso]
giocherai kingdom hearts iii non ho mai
giocato un kingdom hearts purtroppo
purtroppo perché ho giocato altra roba
quand'ero piccolo indo marzo non puoi
giocare a tutti i giochi
lui è uno di quelli che ho sacrificato
attento colbertismo che c'entra certa
gente ci potrebbe anche credere che ci
creda
ti piace destini non gioco mai non
volevo vantare ascolti si di sì molto
poco perché ho iniziato ascoltarli tardi
da piccolo non ascoltavo niente quindi
manca quel pezzo però però non dragon in
veneto è solo faccio raduno in veneto
anche se penso di sì ti aiuta qualcuna
risponde dei fan su instagram
no no perché non riesco a rispondere a
tutti su instagram è impossibile troppa
gente creando riesco si no comunque no
non avrebbe senso
i giochi a fort knight quando porti
mizhuo mizhuo e non lo so può darsi che
lo porterò può darsi che lo porterò
quanto e tastiera è rotto giocando un
sacco e tra l'altro questa tastiera qui
che ciò è particolare perché fa poco
rumore quando giochi perché ci aiuta i
tasti piatti quindi è figo bella giose
classe 1000 e perché i tasti piatti il
problema qui quindi quindi non si
sentono tanto quando giochi sempre fatto
apposta perché magari registra prima che
non la fanno più mi disse si rompe
questa cielo nel culo non la fanno più
quelli della rete sono pazzi ad averla
tolta dal commercio pazzi che andava
tantissimo non so come va tolta pazzi
grazie a essa me è un barboncino toy
devo soffermi il naso dove mi ci ha
lasciati fazzoletti non c'e gli occhi
ti seguo da prima dei 100 capo e la
madonna
grazie a me neanche io sia un bacino chi
guarda ma nei primissimi video di lory
60 search lori 600 56 il mio primo
canale di youtube
wow cosa facevi facevo vedrà se c'è
ancora
mamma mia
questo è il primo canale di youtube
questo qua trick shot il cam clips
montage il gameplay
insomma sharon mai ciano mamma mia quota
player bambinello iscritto il 30 aprile
del 2007 avevo esattamente dodici anni
fatto il calcolo 12 anni appena fatti
47.000 ok questo canale era pieno di
video pieno lì o cancellati tutti perché
sono un deficiente erano darei un arto
per recuperare quei video
ho provato a contattare youtube un
casino nessuno mi ha mai saputo ridare
quei video pazzo questo è il mio primo
video cioè mio primo video il mio avviso
più vecchio su youtube ma non è il mio
primissimo video tutti quelli che ho
cancellato sono pazzo ad averli cacciati
perché per motivi strani di copyright
deficiente questo giochino delle palle
che forse avevo portato anche sul canale
questo che dovevi fare tutto sta scalata
al contrario arrivare qua tac e poi
tornare tutti indietro e poi prendi
questa cosa che sarà la parte più di
fiat tipo un super meat boy un po strano
questo era l'ultimo video del canale di
questo canale qua
[Musica]
semplicemente io tutto questo perché non
faceva capire però sono stato un pazzo
togliere tutto un pazzo pazzo pazzo
maniaco quanto darei per recuperare
tutti quei ecco i video quanto da lei
della gente che sta venendo qua perché
era il mio primo figlio abo cioè non è
il mio primo video è la gente pensa che
sia il mio primo video ma non lo è giuro
non è mica lì non averne meno male che
non sapete quali sono i miei video non
avete idea avete idea bella player gamer
piper rock n roll
thank you so much for the nation man
profit so se ci fai vedere se m come lo
sta dormendo
se viene qua lo tiro su però non sta non
sa non possono anche venire perché c'è
la videocamera appiccicata non posso
toglierlo si stacca la live non basta
dormendo alessio
ciao alessio grazie mille mi sento si è
toccata quando leggo same lascio a te lo
so ti sta piacendo del terreno è molto
molto molto bello del tar one molto
molto carino da quando hai l'orecchino
da sempre nel senso da quando
dell'orecchino nel senso con drake lo
prendevo della serie a non dava mai
visto capito orecchino cielo da cinque
anni quasi più
hai mai fatto vedere la tua casa attuale
no non sono quel tipo di click byte
click day toe in altri modi grazie
guglielmo quasi ora di mettere
decorazioni di natale sullo sfondo si
perchè secondo te io ho la faccia di uno
che ci ha voglia ma di melo non giovano
non lo farò mai
cosa ne pensi di lewis su un super
talento naturale perché gli viene
proprio naturale fare certe cose
quindi tanta roba c'è pensi a tipo uno
degli youtuber per eccellenza perché gli
viene proprio easy fare certe robe tra
l'altro assurde molto molto bravo sempre
si del taro ne è già detto fischio
e stato divertente vedere te youtube
rewind e non più di paese
che strano che pd poi non c'era nel in
questo rewind a proposito minchia
speriamo che più di pai ma dolce ho
pensato adesso speriamo che finché pd
poi faccia un video dove è commenta il
rewind perché se lo fa io sarò io vidi
più di bari speriamo sarebbe troppo figo
sarebbe troppo figo vedere se facesse la
reaction al di wine e se ci fossi io nel
rewind sarebbe utilissimo
non lo so salve finissimo per ciò che
facciamo pensato adesso ci ha pensato
voi volete saperlo invece chi c'è nel
nel rewind signori
volete sapere chi è che è dentro un
video di più di pai oltre youtube e poi
non lo sapete voi non ci crederete mai
poi non ci crederete mai quando ve lo
dirò ma sapete chi è dentro più video di
pai non solo uno più video di in
capitoli più di pai c'è dentro questa
persona voi non avete idea adesso vela
trova adesso che la trovo ve lo giuro
ospedale adesso che la trovo una persona
che conosco molto bene è dentro un video
di pippa che se la trova la faccio
vedere però devo trovarlo perchè cavolo
ma sto trovando aspettato
ci prova a vedere non so se c'è
porca vacca non lo trovo cavolo far
vedere troppo minchia non lo trovo viene
ha sentito porca vacca schifosa non lo
trovo
vabbè ma lo trovo non ve lo farò vedere
non lo trovo
no non c'è pietro no se gioca piedi non
lo trovo cappio che sfiga non riesco a
trovarlo perché moglie lo chiede al
diretto interessato
cazzo non lo trovo gli lo scrivo ridammi
video dove c'è il pacchetto messo dentro
il nuovo troppo alte broni passi al volo
il video di più di fi dove ci sei tu
dimmi troverò lo trovò poi sono in live
lo vedo in diretta se vuoi dopo che mi
passi link entra in cioè entra nel
guarda il mio canale che lo vedo in
diretta perché non stava andando mia
risposta arriva knight idea di chi c'è
nel video di più di pai
ma c'è non avete idea giuro
alcuni l'hanno beccato che lo sapete hai
pensato di kireka il no chao fa vi
volevo sapere cosa ne pensi dell'uscita
di scena di rick grimes in the walking
dead
prima ancora che spuntasse pump spero di
averti fatto spogliare un bacio julie no
penso che tu l'abbia fatta tutti gli
altri però no perché io ho smesso di
seguire the walking dead perché mi
sembrava troppo la stessa pappina dopo
un po era tipo era tipo come si dice
raggiungi un luogo resisti finché poi
vai via raggiungere un altro rogo dei
sistemi che poi poi vai via
raggiungi altro luogo era diventato
sempre così quindi milano rotto le palle
di guardarlo peccato perché non era male
non è male neanche adesso però io per
per piacermi una cosa a me deve
veramente se è bella con la b maiuscola
se no
questo problema vorrei farmi piacere
tutto non riesco
c'è chi riesce a guardare qualsiasi cosa
a quelle bellissimo quelle bellissime
pole e bellissimi vorrei essere così
saprei come impiegare molto meglio il
mio tempo ma non sono così per farmi
piacere una serie un film ci vuole un
sacco 3 2 1 no non è scontato porti
getting over it ancora no speriamo di no
però mi mimì mi sono sempre chiesto
perché non abbia ancora fatto il getting
over it 2 il creatore perché ci mette
niente a fare getting over il secondo me
una volta che ha già gli assets del del
gioco ci mette niente a farne a fare due
perché devi niente no però dedicare la
mappa
il concept di gioco ce l'hai già è già
tutto scriptato di ciò che era la parola
cazzo fallo perchè non l'ha fatto il 2
pazzo il creatore di getting over che
avrei fatti mille se avesse avuto sto
poterli a sé ma in passato il video però
no
intanto il pd sembra che mi piace molto
l'ho visto due volte tutto quindi
minchia che ci sono tipici cinque
stagioni da 20 episodi l'una e ogni
episodio dura 50 minuti quindi pensa
quanto mi è piaciuto
sto morendo soffocato dal naso eccolo
qua sta cercando che serve un aiuto più
di pai bar non penso all ici per t
series ma tutti i miei iscritti sono
descritte più di paioni non potrei
cambiare nulla
clip ai non raggiungeranno mai
impossibile ma in volta che si avvicina
t series cosa porterai al canale con i 5
milioni di iscritti
voi non avete idea dello speciale 5
milioni di siti non è solo lo speciale
più bello che abbia mai fatto è uno gli
speciali più belli di youtube italia lo
sto girando da settimane sto finendo di
girarlo in questi giorni lo stiamo
girando da settimane che non registro i
miei video normali perché devo
registrare lo speciale 5000 e non ho
ancora fatto niente nessuno spoiler non
avete idea dello speciale 5 milioni non
avete idea a ditelo tutti i vostri amici
non di non non diego ai miei video chi
se ne frega ma di guardare lo speciale 5
milioni perché il video più bello che io
abbia mai fatto è che farò mai in tutta
la mia vita sarà imbattibile imbattibile
abbiamo il video ok
vai e guarda la clip blog ci siete
perché così poche views a perché
semplicemente un re yacht
no no vabbè che non è né scherzavo non
riusciamo
siete questo video di phillip high dove
c'è un mio amico le pronti gli applausi
perché non lo trovava per un altro volta
caricato da un set di pai quindi si vede
che lui venga caricato sul suo canale
siete quanto a grinta degli action in
euroleague skyrim tumori o di oblivion
[Musica]
no a perché l'ha fatta due volte la
reaction sta roba peccato ciccio merino
su più di pa non si vede la faccia
perché c'è una qualità vera perché
questo clima ha preso il video di ciccio
e la ricarica commentato quindi ha preso
il video era ricaricato sul suo canale
quindi è già perso qualità poi uno ha
scaricato il video di più di baila messo
sul suo canale quindi ha perso di
qualità pure visibili by quindi la
faccia di ciccio è sparita in tutto sta
perdita di qualità però lui e cc
e ciccio intanto domani c'è guido c'è
anche lui nel finale di the forest
scritto manin ore detto anche su mya
canale
io l'ho invitato prima di te bastardo
scherzando ti voglio bene a felix
iscrivetevi a canali pd by così t series
iscrivetevi tutti maledizione
ho vinto io comunque cielo ho avuto io
prima ciccio ceci c'è un canali pd parma
ciccio non per caso c'è ciccio proprio
fatto bene nel si vede proprio bene non
in quel video che non si vede una sega
però c cioè in un canale di ba limitava
le persone che si muovono in skyrim che
sono molto strane quando si un po c è un
artista sotto varie vari punti di vista
nel senso che lui è brava a ballare fa
ridere ed è molto mimico sono di brevi
molto chimico nel senso alle cose che fa
le fa molto bene proprio con i movimenti
riesce a far ridere ha detto è un
talento talent un tale cioè non ce n'è
proprio iscrivetevi a pilibhit che deve
superare vabbè tanto ci è più famosi da
essi in quel viso si cappero se famoso
non so quanti milioni ha fatto quel
video tanti tanti bravo ciccio bravo
bravo cazzo ma io ho la cosa più bella
di più di pai
ma la cosa più bella di ragazzi che è
questa bella a tutti i ragazzi
consigliere se qualcuno di provare
bungee jumping
sì sì perché è un'esperienza che almeno
una volta e da fare poi non lo farete
mai più ve lo assicuro perchè vi cagate
addosso però una storia da una storia
una volta da fare una volta da fare
almeno è veramente figo la prossima
serie che fanno in là i valori alle
prossime live ragazzi farò un po di
gioco con un po di amici come facevano
le prime live e questo in attesa di
trovare una serie nuova che porto ha
risposto ciccio però grazie di cuore per
le parole prego perché ti voglio bene
anch'io ti va tanto vento
io voglio un sacco di baciccio un sacco
un bravo ragazzo oltre che un talentuoso
ragazzo è capitato mai ora fan sotto
casa
se ai tempi di citofonavano pensionato
via da torino
hai sentito nella controverse riguardi
della controversia riguardo bethesda no
ma nuova rete resta ma ma riguardo a
fallout 76 cosa mi il supporto clienti
ha mostrato dati sensibili di alcuni
utenti ticket aperti negli utenti
riguardo fa l'associazione da me li
hanno mandati ad altri utenti a cazzo
non lo sapevo minchia pure circa otto
pazienti che di supporto aver riscattato
nel real suo sito web
non lo sapevo mi informerò e poi
guarderò bene non lo sapevo ma voglio
dedicarla live a questo molto strano
perché beth esami che gigante come è
possibile non l'ho letto e vogliamo sta
dormendo non posso svegliare il mio cane
per i mille views io lo faccio perché io
sono io ma chiuso the fun cool amazing
magic five faiti la vita domani esce il
super smash siamo al senato io no ciccio
sicuramente lo è ciccio si fa di
endovena
il super smash tra un video di più de
bahia el altra pecca ciao pecca di
milano anziani
cosa faresti se youtube finisse per
colpa l'articolo 13 ma non non lo so boh
non lo so io me la vivo tranquillissima
mente vi sono più preoccupato da
spettatore che da chieda fluida così
quello che fa contenuti è che non mi so
esprime più procurato da spettatore
perché lo guardo la mente tanto e
youtube
nel tempo libero quel poco che ciò per
il resto no perché io lavoro anche al di
fuori youtube quindi non è il mio unico
lavoro non è che sto sotto un ponte però
mi dispiacerebbe tratto mi chiama mia
casa quindi perché sei brutto ma tu
mamma non diceva così ieri il cane dorme
non posso la figlia di huawei è stato
arrestato a l'ho vista l'ho visto
non ho visto che l'hanno arrestata ho
visto l'articolo strano cioè non so più
cosa però trattata grazie blog grazie
pecca ma i cavalli come sarebbero senza
gambe bruttissimi
segui mister beast regaleresti come fa
lui così tanti soldi ha il braccino
corto no io ho il braccino cortissimo
tra i liguri
combattiamo così viva tipi di rex e poi
non penso di avere l'amore i soldi da
mister beast dio mi è piaciuto
partecipare i tipi di wine è stato molto
bello perché così pochi spettatori
perché sono le undici e perché non me ne
frega un cazzo sono fare i titoli
kickback giocherei a rob e kate ma non
me ne frega ma se io lo feci vivere in
una città grande in un paesino piccolo
attualmente in una città grande perché
in un paesino più piccolo la connessione
fa schifo
infatti prima via quindi un paesino
piccolo grazie carmine perché non hai
fatto vi do il video di quando sei
venuto nella grande mela
io non sono mai venuto a new york
per un attimo controllato se new york la
grande mela déjà vu e già questo lapsus
non sono venuto a new york mai quindi
non so chi tu abbia visto non si è finto
me non ero io
ciò sarà il ciao matteo sono venuto un
miliardo di volta a los angeles è andato
a 9 volte a los angeles mai a new york 9
8 volte a los angeles una volta in texas
e l'ultima volta
anaheim minchia non mi ricordavo vicino
al texas dove incontrato marco layer che
non lo youtube rewind
ma lo studio quando lo farai vedere e
[Musica]
come faccio e piccolo un giorno ve lo
farò vedere tra poco raggiunto i 5
milioni di iscritti grazie mille per
avermelo detto non lo sapevo giocherei
ai vecchi retrogame non lo so perché non
sono molto da youtube ha regalato la
playstation mini quindi potrei farlo
ciao giulia grazie mille
come si chiama canali ciccio i parco
giochi ragazzuoli io direi che potrei
concluderla qua e un pò prima oggi
perché finito primarie prossima live che
faremo
come si dice ci sono dei periodi in cui
io faccio la tipo adesso abbiamo fatto
all'inizio lection poi faccio adesso
farò un paio di live insomma faro del
cazzeggio con dei miei amici quindi
rocket league
no vero poi c'era un'altra serie ok
quindi adesso prendiamo un attimo di
pausa dalla serie poi inizierò questo va
bene per me possiamo concluderla sono
molto contento di aver finito le isole
shaun ecco perché se andato abitare a
milano per la connessione appunto per
quelli tra la tata tata tata grazie alla
tarie su brutto se carinissimo lo so
forse da farmi filmare le case ne ha
voglia
certo verrò a cagliari sicuramente non
sono venuti sa bene ecco in sardegna non
ci sono venuto per un raduno non sono
venuto in sardegna molise ma no sono
punti molise ricordo di sicuro non in
australia in trentino
non mi ricordo o in friuli comunque ok
regioni non ha fatto tra cui la sardegna
che di ferro ti è piaciuta live di oggi
si perché è molto tranquilla senso ho
fatto un 45 odiare isole shaun ora è
quarto di domande
rondoni
e si vede che sei stanco ragazzi io sono
stanco sempre la mia faccia e questa non
sono stato io sono stanco per n quindi
non è vero
ogni volta che vedo la gente in giro
minchia si vede che hai dormito poco non
gli sono così ho dormito 8 ore stanotte
stai tranquillo e non sono state sono
stanco sempre che non vi preoccupate
questa vitalità a prescindere sempre
somma ci fosse venuto in abruzzo anche
in abruzzo ha intenzioni prevede altri
cani no già uno impossibile da tenere
non hai fatto la lombardia sera a 6 nel
video del rewind bo devo soffermi il
naso larga domando chi era lei perché
devo soffiarmi il naso non nuovo
fazzoletto sono caduto e ho battuto le
costole sul comodino ti sono vicino solo
tira manfredonia spero verrai un bacino
manfredonia per te ciao dani thank you
so much for the nation
ho detto più di pace guardato l'aiba
speriamo signori
spero che vi sia piaciuto è finito un po
prima oggi però abbiamo finito prima
possiamo concludere qua
spero che vi sia piaciuto come se vi è
piaciuta sono come è un mi piace anche
vari social che come l'esatta
descrizione si schieri e noi ci vediamo
come sempre come sempre al prossimo
video da ragazzi